hello film courage subscribers my name
is Daniel soul I'm a festival director
of the highlights towards film festival
just an interview with dave and karen
for film courage hope you all get to
check it out and hope it's a formative
and helps outside of that we we all
decided Dave Karen and I that we want to
give stuff away back you know back to
the film career subscribers and that we
need how much Chris felt we want to give
some some some free submissions to the
festival so we're gonna give to free
submissions to the film festival for
this year our next deadline coming up is
April twelfth for the regular deadline
May twenty-fourth for late and you know
we figured a fun way to do this is a
myself I'm gonna added record collector
now of a lot of random records obscure
records good and bad and so we felt to
be good to uh to throw some records your
way and see if you can guess the the
artist behind the record first person to
answer correctly in the comment section
will win the free submission and again
we give them away to submissions will
have two separate records to showcase
and best of luck see what Holly towards
you